m
faisant le massif du mont-blanc offrait
aux touristes l'une des plus belles
excursions du monde entier
de chamonix le téléphérique le plus haut
d'europe les conduisait jusqu'à
l'aiguillé du midi à 3800 mètres et de
la leur faim jusqu'en italie le survol
de la vallée blanche et du glacier du
géant
et voici que s'est produit le drame un
drame stupide jour là qui était
exceptionnellement beau 87 personnes
avaient tenté les 30 cabines du
téléphérique pour le voyage de cinq
kilomètres au dessus du vide à 25
kilomètres à l'heure chaque télécabine
emportait un maximum de quatre voyageurs
à la découverte de ce spectacle unique
et tout à coup l'un prévu l'incroyable
se produisait un avion de chasse
surgissait et sectionné le câble autres
acteurs
et des télécabines s'emballait c'était
la catastrophe
[Musique]
totalement décroché lé s'écraser 150
mètres plus bas où le riz témoigne
tristement aujourd'hui de la mort de
leurs six occupants les autres
télécabine restait suspendu entre ciel
et terre
les secours aussitôt s'organiser du côté
français comme du côté italien et le
sauvetage n'était pas facile et malgré
l'intervention des hélicoptères
voyageurs allait passer une nuit
dramatique dans le froid et la theurre
prisonniers du vide à 3500 mètres
d'altitude
l'aspirant guide christian moulié devait
tenter lui de se tirer de tout seul en
utilisant le câble sectionné au long
duquel il cessa descendre à la force du
poignet une descente de 150 mètres au
bout de laquelle il arrive est épuisé
mais sains et saufs
l'envoi sera dure et 20h drame a fait
six victimes et l'on se dit que c'est
une espèce de miracle qu'il n'y en ait
pas eu 87
à la ménagère qui s'interroge sur le
prix des légumes faudra-t-il répondre
qu'il y a du chemin à parcourir depuis
le lieu de la récolte mais ce chemin
explique-t-il que le prix ait pu doubler
et plus entre le départ et l'arrivée
oui sans doute si l'on imagine que des
produits récoltés dans un département du
centre passe par exemple par les halles
de paris
[Musique]
si l'on imagine que d'un intermédiaire à
l'autre ces produits finissent par
reprendre le chemin d'un département
voisin de leur lieu d'origine
or il faut le dire peut-être circuit
n'est pas impossible alors on a vu les
producteurs bretons vendre eux-mêmes
leurs choux fleurs dans les rues de
paris simplification radicale certes du
circuit les impossibles à l'échelon
national
c'est donc de l'organisation des marchés
qu'il faut attendre une amélioration
véritable d'abord au stade de la
production c'est l'exemple du marché de
châteaurenard dont les haut parleurs
ouvre aux acheteurs la production de
toute une région avec contrôle constant
des cours
c'est encore l'exemple à lyon du nouveau
marché gare vaste installation qui avec
leurs seize hectares sont sans doute
actuellement parmi les plus importantes
d'europe qui est routier et qui est de
chemin de fer
[Musique]
bureau de poste
bureau de police et de douane
4h30 c'est l'heure du grand rush
contacts multiples producteurs de la
région acheteurs commissionnaires
détaillants producteurs expéditeurs
toutes les opérations commerciales ont
l'avantagé ici de bénéficier à chaque
instant de la connaissance des cours
donnés par le chef des ventes et c'est
en définitive par une diminution de prix
de revient que se traduit l'effet d'un
tel marché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le marché de montlhéry va plus loin
encore la vente sur échantillons qui s'y
pratique élimine tout manutention seuls
les échantillons entrent dans la salle
où sous les yeux des acheteurs installés
sur les gradins un cadran propose les
enchères des croissants
une simple pression sur un bouton arrête
la vente au prix a dit c'est une
économie de 25 % qui serait réalisée
lisa sion des grands marchés 25% dont
devraient bénéficier producteurs et
consommateurs
sommes-nous sur le point de voir révéler
la vie inconnue des étrusques entre
cerveteri est arc ligne 1 l'équipe du
professeur carlo de lerici grâce à ces
méthodes de détection se propose de
détecter et de visiter des milliers de
tonnes jusqu'ici ignoré le professeur de
lerici a tout simplement imaginer
d'utiliser pour la recherche
archéologique le matériel de forage
utilisé pour les recherches minières une
performeuse permet d'arriver au vide
d'une chambre funèbre un périscope point
sa place et manipulé depuis la surface
permet une investigation visuel
suffisantes pour juger de l'intérêt
historique et artistique du tombeau
grâce à cette méthode pendant les cinq
dernières années le professeur de lerici
à inventorier 2500 tomba chambre
mortuaire découvert 20 ans ma peinture
est réuni plus de 6000 pièces
artistiques
ainsi en appliquant à l'archéologie les
moyens géophysique réservé jusqu'ici à
la prospection industriels le savant
italien aura t'il rendu un immense
service à la recherche archéologique
grâce à ses moyens les fouilleurs
peuvent choisir à bon escient la tombe
riche d'enseignements qui les paiera de
leur peine au lieu de perdre beaucoup de
temps tâtonnements et en efforts
inutiles muette depuis 2500 ans la
civilisation étrusque va-t-elle enfin
parler
[Musique]
belgrade capitale des pays non engagé
selon la formule consacrée maintenant à
celle qui tourne sous ce qu'arnaud
président de la république indonésienne
modibo keita président de ma vie hassan
ii roi du maroc en tout 24 délégations
réunies pour affirmer la position du
troisième bloc
[Musique]
étaient présents le colonel nasser l'un
des leaders de cette conférence au
sommet l'évêque macario ce directeur de
conscience de la république de chypre et
le président bourguiba dont c'était
l'apparition dans ce tiers mais si la
conférence n'a pas condamné comme on s'y
attendait la surprise nucléaire venus de
moscou il n'en est pas moins vrai que le
geste de l'urss a suscité dans son
ensemble les regrets de la conférence
dénotera liste
en france est allée en urss est
aujourd'hui très facile l'urss est en
effet à sa bande à la porte de
versailles sous la forme d'une
exposition compte inaugurer un ministre
soviétique monsieur patate chef et un
ministre français monsieur janet
si l'image que veut donner d'elle-même
l'urss comportent un certain décor de la
vie aujourd'hui très général elle se
singularise un montant en épingle ses
réalisations cosmique les capsules de
gagarine et de guitares et les spoutniks
de toutes sortes y tiennent bien entendu
la place d'honneur mais à côté de cette
démonstration de puissance l'exposition
soviétique de paris a voulu aussi faire
impression par d'autres moyens et
l'offensive de charme a été menée
tambour battant par la mode moscovite
e
[Musique]
on ne s'improvise pas pirates même au
cinéma encore faut-il savoir un tant
soit peu manier l'épée le sabre évolué
avec le maximum d un saut au milieu des
plus rudes par rapport c'est la raison
qui a amené les vedettes d'une
superproduction de la meilleure
tradition à se frotter aux cascadeurs
italiens eux qui n'ignore rien des
secrets du métier
il reste que se laisser tomber de 20
mètres même quand le point de chute a
été consciencieusement rembourrés n'est
pas à proprement parler un exercice de
tout repos
et
dans sa conférence de presse tenue
devant 800 journalistes du monde entier
le général de gaulle a abordé les
problèmes de l'algérie du sahara de
bizerte de l'agriculture mais il a avant
tout marqué la position française sur
berlin après les menaces des soviets
ceux ci
veulent par la force
réduire les positions et coupé les
communications
des alliés à berlin
les alliés doivent par la force
maintenir leur position et maintenir
leur communication
assurément de fil en aiguille comme on
dit et si tout cela fait multiplier les
actes hostiles des soviets acte
auxquelles il faudrait répondre
on pourrait en venir
à la guerre générale
mais alors
c'est que les soviets l'aurait
délibérément voulue
et dans ce cas tout recul préalable de
l'occident
n'aurait servi qu'à l'affaiblir et à le
diviser
et sans empêcher l'échéance
un certain point de menaces de la part
d'un impérialisme ambitieux
ou recul
a pour effet de surexcités l'agresseur
de le pousser à redoubler sa pression
et finalement
facilite est apte son assaut
au total
actuellement
les puissances occidentales
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen de servir la
paix du monde
que de rester droite et ferme
après l'attentât commis contre la
personne du général de gaulle et dont la
nouvelle avait stupéfié la france et le
monde entier monsieur roger frey
ministre de l'intérieur comment tel
événement devant la presse et en donner
un premier récit détaillé il se
confirmait que c'était sur la route de
collombey entre nogent et romilly
qu'avait été placé une énorme charge
d'explosifs au tas de sable avait servi
à dissimuler une machine infernale dont
une déficience technique à forte
heureusement empêcher le plein
fonctionnement et dont on retrouvait
encore des éléments le land
la déflagration avait été perçue aux
alentours
un double file de 350 mètres enfouis
dans la terre aboutissait à un bosquet
où avait été opéré la mise à feu de ce
bosquet le guetteur on sait qu'il a été
arrêté pouvait embrasser toute la
portion de route de part et d'autre de
l'engin est donné le signal au moment
opportun
[Musique]
le dimanche à colombes et le général de
gaulle l'avait voulu changer en rien ses
habitudes et l'homme qui avait dit après
l'attentât c'est une plaisanterie de
mauvais goût se rendait comme à
l'accoutumée à l'église du village au
milieu de l'émotion qu'on imagine on
imagine aussi l'écho qu'a rencontré le
geste criminel en france car la france
se souvenait elle se souvenait des
tristes heures de l'exode
elle se souvenait de la voix qui
s'étaient élevées pour animer l'espoir
est sans doute ce sont ses souvenirs qui
appartiennent à l'histoire et qui
appartiennent aussi à la légende qui
donne un poids plus lourd encore à la
réprobation que suscite l'attentât
d'aujourd'hui car la france sait ce que
représente l'homme qui avait relevé les
armes de la nation et qui devait tenir
ensuite une place importante dans son
destin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le brésil cette semaine aura été celle
de l'apaisement douze jours après la
démission sensationnel du président
antoine roth 12 jours qui ont vu le
brésil au bord de la guerre civile le
vice président monsieur zhao bollaert a
pu finalement rentré à brasilia retour
dont l'aspect triomphale est à la mesure
de l'inquiétude ressentie
pour accéder au poste suprême que lui
réservent à la constitution monsieur
goulard a dû accepter la décision du
congrès d'abandonner le régime
présidentiel est de faire du brésil la
première république parlementaire du
nouveau monde il s'agit d'un compromis
sans doute mais le brésil respi
la sphère de bizerte entre hôtels dans
la voie du règlement c'est dans l'écho
des paroles prononcées par le président
bourguiba dont le ton nouveau a détendu
les relations franco tunisiennes que
s'est déroulée à menzel jemil dans le no
man's land entre les deux barrages les
changes des prisonniers sous l'égide de
la croix-rouge
740 soldats et civils tunisiens ont été
remis par les troupes françaises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de leur côté les tunisiens rendait la
liberté à 220 français 184 civils et 36
militaires
pour la grande bretagne cette semaine
aura été celle des regards levés vers le
ciel afin de bord où se tient chaque
année le salon de l'aviation britannique
l'exposition statique ne manquait certes
pas d'intérêt on ya vu notamment le
bluestreak qui sera le premier étage de
la première fusée européenne de
recherche spatiale
[Musique]
mais ce sont les présentations en vol
qui ont comme d'habitude retenu
l'attention mondiale en général et
soviétique en particulier
[Applaudissements]
du reste les hélicoptères à usage
militaire n'avait plus rien à apprendre
à personne non plus que le short et ses
seins à décollage vertical qui n'en est
pas à son coup d'essai mais demeure en
raison de son étrangeté une attraction
il épuisé
il reste que la participation des
parachutistes britanniques à apporter à
la grande parade de farnborough des
moments de sa vie d'émotion tels ces
sauts groupe est de 60 secondes de chute
libre
il reste aussi qu'on a vu pour la
première fois en vol le répète 115 la
flèche volante prototypes des
long-courriers supersonique de demain
[Applaudissements]
il reste enfin qu'avec les patrouille
acrobatique de la royal air force les
ailes britanniques ont donné une image
saisissante de l'aviation d'aujourd'hui
m
à bruxelles nous avons surpris ce
cuisinier affairés autour de ses
fourneaux mais le dernier plat ranger
pourquoi et change-t-il sa top contre un
chapeau de cowboy
[Musique]
ouais nous avons surpris aussi ce
directeur de société qui ferme ses
dossiers à la fin d'une journée
épuisante
pourquoi chose il soudain des bottes
les plus dignes personnage de bruxelles
serait il saisit par la manie du
travesti
voici l'explication à tremelo à 35 km de
bruxelles c'est texas city un far west
de fantaisie ou un club peu banale
français quelques 80 membres un ersatz
de la vie des cowboys on a paraît-il
rien trouvé de mieux pour effacer les
effets déprimant de notre vie moderne
des magistrats des hommes d'affaires des
respirateurs des ouvriers viennent s'y
abandonnent leur personnalité pour
retrouver leurs rêves dansants ne
s'appelle plus que james hook bill
rien ne manque à texas city ni les
chevaux ni les fusils ni le classique
saloon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les yachts et
[Musique]
de noter retire le cuisinier des postes
l'avocat c'est cool et le
président-directeur général en profite
pour remporter la caisse
et tous ces joyeux personnages
ressuscite pour danser le quadrille des
pionniers
qu'on se garde de jeter un jugement trop
hâtif c'est peut-être pour les surmené
la solution de l'avenir
[Musique]
aux jeux équestres de rotterdam en
hollande les garçons de piste ont eu
beaucoup de travail cavaliers et chevaux
sans s'en donner à coeur joie le
concours d'obstacles s'est rapidement
transformée en petit jeu de massacre
[Musique]
de temps à autre pour ne pas faire comme
tout le monde certains concurrents
franchissent le mur sans bavure presque
par inadvertance
on augmente la difficulté
le mur est à deux mètres 10 c'est encore
un peu plus de travail en perspective
pour les garçons de piste voilà qui est
fait
ce cavalier en revanche a l'air de
vouloir rompre la monotonie le saut est
impeccable chapeau monsieur
[Musique]
sofia à l'heure des universiades les
universiades ce sont en quelque sorte
les jeux olympiques réservé aux
étudiants de tous les pays du monde la
gymnastique constitue l'une des épreuves
les plus spectaculaires qui soit
le japonais mitsui pour y réaliser un
exploit dans les exercices au sol
limitée par cette jeune fille soviets
[Musique]
des gymnastes soviétique c'était
d'ailleurs la part du lion dans chaque
spécialité titoff au cheval d'arçons de
quoi vous donner le tournis
[Musique]
titoff encore aux anneaux cette fois
[Applaudissements]
pour n'être pas en reste le japonais
mitsiu pour y revient lui aussi une
seconde fois il est aussi brillant à la
barre fixe que dans les exercices au sol
[Musique]
les double barre c'est le royaume des
gymnastes féminines et particulièrement
des soviétiques
je
n'ont elles pas autant de charme ces
jeunes filles que les reines de beauté
des plages à la mode
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
elisabeth ville est passée du calme à la
fièvre puis de la fièvre au drame
l'arrivée des casques bleus de monsieur
amar ch n'avait sans doute pas été
accueillie avec beaucoup de ferveur mais
leur utilisation brutale envie de faire
céder monsieur tshombe est de faire
rentrer le katanga dans le sein d'un
congo unifié a fait lever la tempête ce
pas à elisabethville les casques bleus
sont en difficulté dans le reste du pays
et l'on pense dans le monde que monsieur
achats outrepassé son mandat est
déconsidéré la fonction de l'onu
mais monsieur h n'aura pas survécu à la
crise katangaise qu'il avait soulevé le
secrétaire général de l'onu que son
prédécesseur monsieur trick veulent y
avait accueilli à new york en 1953 est
mort dans un accident d'avion alors
qu'il allait converser avec monsieur
tshombe déjà rencontré l'an dernier des
moyens de faire cesser les combats et
d'arrêter les progrès de la tragique ce
faisant monsieur h qui avait mis l'onu
dans un mauvais qu'à tenter sans doute
d'en circonscrire les effets néfastes
le tragique accident dont il vient
d'être victime va-t-il hâter le
dénouement de la faire ce qui est
certain c'est que la disparition du
secrétaire général de l'onu va apporter
d'autres perturbations à l'onu
précisément
négociations sur berlin mais dans
quelles conditions elles se comptent
examiner les ministres des affaires
étrangères des états unis france grande
bretagne et allemagne
comme l'a dit monsieur couve de murville
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il
faut négocier mais s'il est possible de
négocier avec la russie
[Musique]
conrad adenauer ou willy brandt c'est
entre ces deux hommes de la partie se
joue et la partie c'est à dire les
élections de l'allemagne fédérale qui
désignait les 497 député du futur
bundestag konrad adenauer 85 ans
chancelier depuis douze ans et leader de
la démocratie chrétienne l'a emporté une
fois encore mais son gouvernement ne
possède plus la majorité absolue il
devra composer avec les libéraux
deux ans après à cap canaveral les
américains réussissent et le lancement
d'une fusée atlas porteuse d'une capsule
mercure d'un poids de 2 tonnes contenant
un astronaute robot désigné sous le nom
de simulateurs d'équipage et qui
respirent transpirent et exprime ses
sensations la récupération s'est opéré
dans les meilleures conditions doit-on
voir maintenant que le vol de gagarine
américain n'est pas loin
les canaux en france vont ils faire une
cure de rajeunissement
on les athlètes un peu oublié c'est vrai
mais voici qu'on a fait une remarque et
une comparaison la remarque marseillais
la porte naturelle sur l'afrique et
l'orient de l'europe industrielle or
l'acheminement des marchandises du nord
vers le sud ou du sud vers le nord ses
expositions à des manutentions complexes
d'abord à l'usagé obligé du rail ensuite
tous deux coûteux pour les matériaux
pondérons la comparaison rotterdam à
l'autre bout de l'europe transite un
tonnage de très loin supérieur mieux
encore il y flotte plus de pavillons
méditerranéen qu'à marseille c'est dire
que le trafic préfère la route la plus
longue vie à gibraltar
un regard sur l'activité du port de
rotterdam donne la clé de ce mystère ici
les matériaux passe directement du
navire qui les apportent dans les
péniche accostée bord à bord car il
existe là un réseau de navigation très
complet vers cette europe industriels
qui s'appelle la ruhr l'allemagne la
belgique voire la lorraine et ce réseau
admet les plus lourds de péniches qui
allie la puissance à l'économie les
nécessaires écluses apparaissent
aujourd'hui dans ce système comme de
véritable ascenseur géant rapide
efficace
en regard la france n'offre que quelques
tronçons à grand débit et pour le reste
un réseau de canaux al'allure filiforme
les écluses qui ne joignent pas
l'efficacité au pittoresque de leurs
mécanismes folklorique bien heureux
quand ces excuses ne s'alignent pas à
perte de vue tous les 50 mètres des
canaux en définitive qui datent du
siècle dernier étrangler parfois vous à
petite vitesse sous peine d'endommager
les rides un décor bucolique 102 mais
aussi parfois d'oubli
[Musique]
et
des ports ainsi ce sont rouillées des
usines sont mortes faute de
l'approvisionnement bon marché que leur
avaient apporté des matières premières a
mené à peu de frais par les canaux
autant de constatation qui ont fait
naître un grand projet un projet qui
s'appuie sur la canalisation du rhône
l'acce navigables méditerranée mer du
nord par la moselle et parlera des
réalisations déjà jalonnent cette grande
voix ne reçut le grand canal d'alsace
paraît attendre le rajeunissement c'est
à dire l'agrandissement du canal du
rhône au rhin les travaux de la
canalisation de la moselle devrait
aboutir en 1963
et au long du grand canal d'alsace on
peut déjà apercevoir les effets produits
sur ses rives par une telle voie
navigable la naissance du sinn nouvelle
lyon où les chemins de fer par est
aujourd'hui saturée trouverait une
nouvelle source d'opulence dans
l'ouverture de lax nord-sud capable de
donner enfin la vie au moderne port
edouard herriot inutile dans son
isolement
quant à marseille son avenir en serait
évidemment bouleversé puisque les
péniches pourrait venir relayer
directement les navires et en frais peut
enfin véritablement la tête de ligne de
l'europe
auj
bien qu'il ait été baptisé par les
météorologistes d'outre-atlantique d'un
au féminin à l'image de tous les
cyclones et ouragans de ces dernières
années le dernier en date car là
puisqu'il faut l'appeler par son nom ne
laissera que de mauvais souvenirs son
approche avait jeté la terreur en
louisiane et au texas c'est par
centaines de milles comme ebbett ont fui
devant lui balayant la côte du golfe du
mexique à la vitesse effrayante de 250
km heure car la marque et sa route de
ruines qui font de lui l'un des plus
destructeurs des ouragans de tout le
xxème siècle
nous
et
des villes ont été effacés de la carte
et pour tous ceux les évacuer d'hier qui
regagne ce qui fut leur toit c'est un
spectacle poignant qui les attend 31
morts dénombrés de nombreux disparus des
dégâts matériels évalués pour l'instant
à 50 milliards d'anciens francs quel est
le bilan encore provisoire hélas de
l'ouragan karl
que dakar connaissent les inondations
l'événement s'il peut se produire est
tout de même assez rare pour qu'on le
remarque des pluies d'une abondance
inaccoutumée ont en effet provoqué dans
les faubourgs de dakar des inondations
heureusement sans gravité mais l'on a
connu dans ces quartiers les scènes
typiques d'un monde envahi par l'eau
quasi non des routes coupées voitures
transformées en barque à moteur le
cortège traditionnel de l'inondation
sous tous les climats rien de tragique
heureusement
[Applaudissements]
ces concours de pompier n'est pas un
épisode de la guerre froide bien qu'il
se déroule à voronej et qu'il met en
scène les étés njord incendie de toutes
les russies
tout le problème est ici un problème de
vitesse et ses équipes qu'elles soient
de moscou de krasnodar de rostov sur le
don d'une vision assez nette de la
question qu'il s'agisse du déroulement
des tuyaux ou du parcours du pompier
style parcours du combattant
mais tout cela n'est rien en regard de
l'épreuve d'ascension avec échelle
mobile le voyait plus tôt
[Musique]
oh
m
à travers trois départements les plus
pauvres de france le général de gaulle à
rechercher pour la quatorzième fois
depuis son retour au pouvoir le contact
avec le peuple français certains
parlaient de désaffection populaire
d'éloignement des organisations avaient
lancé des mots d'ordre recommandé
l'absence où l'abstention est cependant
le président de la république a retrouvé
l'accueil chaleureux que lui ont fait
jusqu'ici toutes les provinces et
acclamé aussi bien à villefranche de
rouergue garonnaise à millau qu à
annonay il a pu au cours de vingt
allocution aussi bien sur l'avenir de
l'algérie que sur les problèmes de la
transformation économique du monde
moderne faire appel à la cohésion
nationale
est cependant ces foules dont il serrait
la main ces villes où il parlait ces
pays qu'ils traversaient compte parmi
les plus déshérités
lozère misère bitton ici d'immenses
déserts de pierre des steppes où le vent
courses en obstacles comptait seulement
par des troupeaux de moutons car le
mouton trouve sa vie partout voilà la
lozère un département mais le plus
abandonner une préfecture de 6000
habitants la plus petite de france si
petit si lointaine que les lignes de
chemin de fer levitte et qu'elle n'est
relié au monde ferroviaire que par une
grosse tête et l'on comprend mieux qu'il
n'y ait ici que seize habitants au
kilomètre carré car la moyenne en france
est de
78,1 pays qui meurt ou plutôt où l'on ne
peut pas vivre trop pauvres trop perdu
et c'est pourquoi tous les ans 3000
lozériens vont chercher fortune ailleurs
et c'est pourquoi chaque année des
villages disparaissent pierre par pierre
après avoir disparu hommes parole et qui
garde encore sur le mont lozère le
village de belles corta des morts
[Musique]
au village de l'hôpital plus de vivants
que les trois personnes qui sont chaque
année bloqué six mois par l'hiver
car l'hiver ici est terrible le vent du
cos est si violent qu'il hérode même les
roches il a rongé le granit ou la
mémoire populaire inscrivit les noms des
deux fils du perron morte perdue dans la
tempête
[Musique]
parfois dans cette solitude désole une
lueur miséricordieuse un village qui se
refuse à mourir et ce spectacle semble
étonnant d'enfants qui dévalent les rues
vers l'école en côtoyant d'autres
bestiaux que des moutons et de
lavandières qui bavardent sans tristesse
mais combien rare car la vie est dure on
vit mal sur cette terre avare derrière
les murs épais construits pour résister
à l'hiver peu de confort et peu de joie
les repas plantureux on les connaît
peut-être aux noces et au fait pour
l'ordinaire c'est plutôt frugal et
comment ne le stresse pas sur ce sol ou
la pomme de terre même grossi mal
sur ses côtes où il ne récolte que des
châtaignes cette nourriture de pauvres
dans ces vallées où la seule richesse
possible était autrefois le mûrier et le
ver à soie industrie précaire et qui
n'enrichit plus son homme si jamais elle
pu le faire bien sûr il ya des truites
dans les rivières
mais la pêche dans les ruisseaux
commencerait telle une industrie tout
est dur âpre difficile
regardez au marché de florac ces visages
marqués par le vent d'un climat sans
pitié par les travaux et les soucis
d'une terre sans bonté tout ici à son
prix est rien et sans valeur il faut
pour n'importe quoi tant de courage
tant de courage dans ce pays perdu alors
que faire de cette lozère essayez de
l'humaniser de l'améliorer de la
convertir on a commencé en donnant de
l'eau à ce pays c'est cool et ruisseaux
abondent des stations de pompage sont
n'ai pas encore beaucoup mais on en est
qu'au début et autour de prades dub
l'ajout de montbrun la terre commence à
changer d'aspect à ispagnac on irait
peut-être pas cru hier il y a un jour
d'hui 600 hectares de champs de fraises
à côté des prairies où le gros bétail
peut vivre des cultures nouvelles sont
essayés on pourra améliorer ses terres
indigente et hors d'atteinte du vent
terrible qui dessèche tous qui usent les
derniers sol dans les cuvettes et les
dépressions on fait des essais
d'ensemencement que feras ton de la
lozère en tout cas on ne la laissera pas
mourir et l'homme qui n'avait tiers que
du courage au fond des yeux il ya
maintenant de l'espérance
débris calcinés des cada une trouée
longue de 100 mètres à travers la forêt
équatoriale c'est la trace du drame qui
a mis fin à la vie de monsieur amar sean
on ignore encore tout des circonstances
du drame et jusqu'à présent les
recherches des enquêteurs n'ont apporté
aux mystères aucun éclaircissement
le cadavre a été transporté à l'église
de ndola en rhodésie du nord monsieur h
avait pris avec monsieur john b ce
rendez vous qui devait lui être funès
les nombres du gouvernement étaient là
pour saluer le corps de l'ex secrétaire
général présent aussi monsieur john b
l'adversaire d'hier
le deuil de l'onu et le problème de la
succession de monsieur h coïncidait avec
l'élection du nouveau président de
l'assemblée générale question certes
plus facile à régler puisque monsieur
mongi slim délégué tunisien rester seul
candidat devant le fauteuil vide de
monsieur marshall l'assemblée à
l'unanimité des suffrages exprimés a
porté le délégué tunisien la présidence
de l'assemblée
mais la succession de monsieur marshall
2 comme il était prévu se heurte à de
nombreuses difficultés qui ne paraissent
pas près d'être résolu
la reprise des essais nucléaires jette
sur le monde une nouvelle inquiétude
c'est ainsi qu à trafalgar square la
plus belle place de londres s'est
déroulée une nouvelle manifestation
contre la reprise de ces essais les
manifestants ayant pris leurs positions
de combat ce qui consistait à s'asseoir
par terre la police 4000 agents n'eut
plus qu'à les déloger avec un maximum de
douceur et à remplir ses paniers à
salade
cette opération mena les uns et les
autres jusqu'à la fin de la soirée il
n'eut plus la nuit venue que les
résistants de la dernière heure et par
sur les trottoirs mais toujours ainsi
je
au milieu des problèmes internationaux
la vie quotidienne conserve ses
exigences que traduit en france
l'expansion économique
qu'il s'agisse d'améliorer le niveau de
vie ou simplement de satisfaire les
besoins d'une population en
accroissement constant dont le car cette
année a pris le chemin de l'école
l'avenir dépend avant tout des
investissements consentis et
spécialement des investissements de base
qui vista la production de fonte et
d'acier produit essentiel à tout progrès
matériel ceci explique en divers points
de france d'immenses chantiers se soit
encore ouvert comme ce magnifique
ensemble sidérurgique qui s'édifie en
leurs rêves
ceci explique aussi que sur le plan
technique la sidérurgie applique à
l'échelle industrielle les découvertes
scientifiques les plus récentes comme
l'utilisation de l'oxygène dans
l'affinage de la faune
ceci explique enfin que 12 100 milliards
d'anciens francs seront dépensés d'ici
1965 pour porter la production française
de l'acier à 25 millions de tonnes
[Rires]
le signal de la grande revanche est
donné après 14 ans d'attentes les
français vont enfin battre les athlètes
britanniques avec jocelyn delecour
monsieur sprint ça ne va pas traîner la
patte pitié pour les anglais y gagnera
également le 200 m et le relais 4 x 100
voilà comment d'un bon ont franchi 2 m 3
cela suffit à idriss pour terminer
premier
le 800 et le quinze 100 m c'est bonnet
blanc blanc bonnet dans chacune de ces
deux courses en effet même scénario dans
le dernier virage michel jazy fait la
nique à ses adversaires pour terminer
avec aisance la facilité actuelle de
jazy frise l'insolence
dans le coin des hommes forts à l'art
n'a peut-être pas la beauté du discobole
antique il n'empêche que le disque qu'il
a lancée a fait un petit vol plané de 53
mètres 90
où va donc cet athlète si pressé il va
se percher si je puis dire à 4 mètres 30
du sol
avec michel macquet il faut faire
attention pour ne pas se faire
transpercer le vomi ordinairement se
placer à plus de 80 mètres c'est à peu
près à cette distance qu'il envoie le
javelot 79 m 63 exactement
robert baugé et le britannique ben ali
20 ans couru pendant près de 29 minutes
pour en arriver là c'est bien
décourageant pour bâle event projet ne
lui laisse aucune chance autrement dit
il a suffi de quelques foulées pas
toujours facile aux français pour
triompher des britanniques par 113 à 99
[Musique]